agenda could be driving the economy into
a ditch
the jobs report was a major miss and
small business owners say they can't
compete with generous unemployment
benefits
paying people more to stay at home
many people want to work no they don't
when you're handing them so much money
and so much unemployment
it's backfiring they're incentivizing
people to stay home
and that just doesn't make sense i would
love to take the un
out of unemployment benefits unless
incentivize employees to come back to
work
but president biden says business owners
like that don't know what they're
talking about
anyone collecting unemployment who is
offered a
suitable job must take the job
or lose their unemployment benefits i
know there's been a lot of discussion
since friday since friday's report that
people are being paid to stay home
rather than go to work we don't see much
evidence of that
i think the people who claim americans
won't work even if they find a good and
fair
opportunity underestimate the american
people
so i was going to go to you dana because
i could hear the steam coming out of
your ears
you're sitting around the corner for me
and i could actually see it was like a
teapot there was smoke coming out of the
door
i figured i'd better go to you which
part of that upsets you more
the fact that he says he doesn't see
that much evidence of it or the fact
that he's never actually ran a business
in his life i think he's never run a
business i don't know before he entered
politics who knows
two parts let's start with the evidence
issue so you've heard this from the
administration since last week
that even though you have anecdotal
evidence and you have business owners
who are saying this you can find like
once an hour on fox news you can
line them up and actually not just on
fox news this is happening at cnn
at msnbc everybody in the news is
talking about this because it's real
and what the administration is asking is
for data that does not actually exist
right you there there's not a
measurement they're trying to tell you
that you have to have data
and evidence as if that mattered in this
case because
there's it's impossible to prove so
they're shifting the burden of proof
under business owners but they are
feeling it they are seeing it and i
actually think that the white house
truly knows this
but here's another thing so last week we
talked to a guy who
runs a restaurant was offering 21 an
hour
for dishwashers still can't get enough
people there
and one of the things that the white
house said today is it's because people
don't get 15
an hour minimum wage but they were
paying six dollars more than that so
again where's your evidence that that's
not true i would
shift the burden of proof back to them
the final thing is i do think there's a
problem
with just perception and that is that
when you when we say something like your
incentive of greg's your point in the
a-block the incentives are off
the incentive is we're gonna give this
money is coming to you and it's not just
an unemployment benefits we know there's
a ton of money going out and lots of
different ways
the incentive is that you make a
rational decision to stay
home or to do something else basically i
think when we're here when you say
something like
they just want to stay on the couch
right it sounds like you're saying oh
they're being lazy when actually
they're just making a rational decision
true for themselves so i think maybe on
the language front
that could be cleaned up yeah it's like
15 bucks to stay
at home versus 20 to wash dishes i'll
eat the five bucks
what do you have to say to dana's cogent
analysis
i know she loves those anecdotes she
loves having guests on the show so i'm
all for dana but i must say
that i think numbers do matter in
economics and if we
really had a labor shortage i think you
would see
wage rates go up and we're not seeing
wages suddenly skyrocketing because
there's a labor
shortage in america that's not the case
in fact
i would also say there's no sign of
inflation out there you look at
something like the 10-year
bonds a 10-year bond right now if you
went out
and bought a 10-year bond right now your
the interest rate's like 1.6
that means people are buying them and
they are buying them
on the premise that inflation is going
to be less than one percent near zero
for the next 10 years
these are people who are in the
financial services business it's their
but it's their business
the gdp right now if it goes at first
quarter rates we would have like a six
percent
growth rate so these are all very
positive yeah we might have some hiccups
there supply chains disruptions
but this is not about anybody being a
you know a lag
a slagger a slacker or somehow lazy no
this is just not who we are and it's not
the american story i can tell you that
jessie what do you uh you want to talk
about the police if i may juan said so
many things that were wrong there i i'm
going to do my best to refute all of
them
uh first of all juan you talk about no
labor shortage there were
seven million job openings last month
and only 250 000 americans took a job
that's what you'd call a shortage of you
see the labor rate
you see the price of labor going up one
hey juan you want to talk about
commodity prices gasoline
food lumber everything's going up and
that's
actually in our research packet so how
did i read the research and you didn't
that's a first
second of all a week with
unemployment benefits all right 800 a
week
let's say your wife also gets 800 a week
you know how much that adds up to a year
one that's 80 grand a year for as dana
said staying on your couch
rational decision to stay on your couch
when you're making
15 000 above the median income level
that's a lot of money that is a lot of
money juan you're going to now say
and this is what biden said which was
the probably the dumbest thing he's ever
said that's why he's an economic
illiterate as greg suggested
he goes well you know what why don't
businesses they just raise wages
oh like these small business owners are
like jerry jones owner of the cowboys
just like
throwing around 20 million dollar
contracts in signing
free agents in the off season these are
mom and pop retail shops and restaurant
owners
they're not just going to be like all
right you know what dishwasher let's
give you 40 grand
hostess let's give you 35 grand they are
small profit margins juan
they don't have money like that to just
raise wages
you got to be out of your mind all right
katie bring it home
or bring it somewhere well i think 2020
was
2020 was the year of the toilet paper
shortage but i think this year 2021 will
be the year of toilet paper being too
expensive because inflation is already
here and more of it is coming
um all right well there you go not a
good
situation no we are not flush
coming up